for example in the in the more mystical
way of understanding christianity it's
like it's not about doing good things to
go to heaven it's never it was never
about that
and it was never about not being able to
do enough good things in order to go to
heaven it's about
becoming something
that you become
heaven you could say
you're transformed into something that's
free
and that's
going up the mountain or moving up
towards something higher so it's more
about so so the idea that let's say you
shouldn't lie
isn't about like well if i lie so many
times and i have so many years in
purgatory or whatever it's about if you
lie you are destroying yourself and
you're destroying the world around you
[Music]
welcome to episode 133 of the michaela
peterson podcast i'm michaela peterson
this is a very special episode because
jonathan pageau a very cool individual
was kind enough to come on and i got to
talk about some topics that i've been
incredibly interested in
for a while for those of you who don't
know jonathan is an artist symbolic
thinker youtuber the editor of the
orthodox arts journal and an expert icon
carver of eastern orthodox icons
you might have heard him on dad's
podcast talk about similar topics we
spoke about my experience finding god
this summer or god revealing himself to
me however you want to put that the
three different branches of christianity
compassion and suffering the meaning in
narrative and how
narrative might be how reality works
something i only recently started to
believe something dad's been talking
about
forever
it's difficult to understand but i think
i'm getting it a bit we spoke about
protestantism and the reformation hell
purgatory and more i asked jonathan a
whole bunch of more religious questions
because i'm still learning
it was really interesting i got kind of
personal although i do do that from time
to time
if you enjoy this conversation please
subscribe your support is greatly
appreciated before we get started this
episode is brought to you by nord pass
running dad's business and my own we
have so many passwords it's absurd i've
used absolutely terrible password
organizers before so i'm happy to be
advertising for nord pass nord nordpass
is made by nordvpn so you know it's a
solid product i can't tell you how much
this has simplified my life nordpass
keeps all your notes and passwords in a
single incredibly secure location only
accessible with your master password it
also monitors password health and data
breaches like facebook and linkedin had
recently it does autofill for passwords
and credit cards scans credit cards so
you don't have to add the numbers into
the app it has an app and a desktop app
and is simple and clean to use it's
great put your online mind at ease with
nordpass
visit nordpass.com
tmpp like the michaela peterson podcast
or use code tmpp before february 10th
and get a free month plus 50 off two
years of nordpass premium there's a
30-day money-back guarantee but this
deal ends on february 10th at
nordpass.com tmpp or using code tmpp at
checkout enjoy the episode
[Music]
i'm so excited about this talk my dad
has been talking about you but he's he's
here in nashville with me right now
we're shooting some courses every
meeting we go to he tells somebody about
you that's
seriously it's a little humbling i have
to say but i i'm happy i i think that
you know when i heard your dad on the
radio in 2015 i just felt like there was
such a
connection between the way we thought
you know and and i think he felt the
same even you know when we met the first
time and so yeah so it's like a i'm
excited to support what he's doing you
know the way that i can so
okay he said yesterday we
we went to a daily wire party and he was
talking to ben shapiro and told ben
shapiro about you he said you guys
should connect but uh um afterwards i
said ben shapiro's probably the smartest
person i've met
it's great like him in person his verbal
fluency it's insane
and dad said uh yeah he's up there among
you know the top three or four people
i've met but he said you were up there
as well
anyway so i'm supposed to call ben
shapiro because i cuz he he sent me his
number so we'll see how that goes it'll
be interesting
that should be really interesting
okay so i guess before we get started
can you give a brief background about
who you are and what you do
and so i um so my name is jonathan i
guess i i live in near montreal i am an
artist let's say
it's the easiest way to understand what
i'm doing is that i guess i'm an artist
i make art for churches liturgical art
and so uh your dad likes to come like an
icon carver is a is even a basser way to
describe me but i would say that
in that
practice i also with my brother metier
who we developed a
an expertise on symbolism or maybe a way
of viewing the world a symbolic way of
viewing the world i try a way to
recapture
how the ancients
perceived reality and try to bridge that
with the modern world in a
modern scientific understanding modern
uh even evolutionary thinking and
everything so i think that at this
moment now i'm probably more involved
and more known for the second part which
is talking about symbolism helping
people understand these old stories in a
better way how they connect to their
lives and even how we can understand
politics or understand
the craziness of our world today through
these old stories and through the
symbolic thinking
okay so how did you get started down
that road
it's one of those things it's hard to
describe you know in my 20s i had a kind
of intellectual spiritual personal
crisis you could say
and i started to search and to read and
to learn and it happened in coordination
with my brother who who also was really
he wrote a book on symbolism called the
language of creation
and we just rediscovered that i'd
rediscovered the the church fathers my
brother was reading kind of rabbinical
commentary and then we started reading
uh i started looking at images and icons
and connecting them to the bible stories
and it just developed on its own
and then all of a sudden you realize
that you've
found a pattern which
you can almost guess what's there right
you could you can at some point you can
look through let's say uh
text for uh let's say a religious
service that you've never seen and not
be at all surprised what you find
because it just basically reveals the
same
uh powerful pattern that you find in
scripture that you find in architecture
and everything
okay we should delve into that
what that pattern is yeah actually let's
just start there
um i don't know if you're gonna be able
to describe that but what's the pattern
that you found
um and so
the best way to maybe the best way to
understand it is that
um
is the way that jordan explains it i
think jordan has a great way of
explaining which is similar to mine and
it's very
easy to understand it that way which is
that
the world presents itself to you as too
much right the world is it's full of
stuff and there's too much stuff and
everything that you perceive has an
indefinite amount of detail and that
detail has you know it's like it's
infinite detail all the way down right
and so
despite that for some reason
we're able to perceive unities
in our experience right i'm able to say
that's an apple but an apple is not one
thing right an apple's a million things
and apple is millions and millions of
things but i'm somehow able to perceive
it as one thing and so but i'm also able
to perceive parts of things and the
unity of things at the same time we kind
of move between the two right i can look
at a car and i can say that's a car that
i could also realize well that's the
wheel of a car that's this part you know
that's the paint that's this so i can
see parts and holes at the same time so
the question is first of all how is that
possible and what does that mean
and so
we have something we have a capacity to
compress reality into unities
so that happens in space
it happens with objects but it also
happens in time
right because time also presents itself
to us as an infinite amount like think
about all the things that are happening
around you right now at this moment
right there are millions of things
happening but you somehow are able to
focus your attention
and then you're also capable of
stringing together
uh elements to create a story
to create a connection between
different aspects of what's going on and
so that's not arbitrary that has a
pattern so there's a way in which we are
able to recognize that
certain events go together and we can
recount them as going together uh and
and like i said it's not it's not an
arbitrary so once you start to see it
you realize that
for example in the the bible in genesis
what it's describing as it's describing
the creation of the world is something
like that
it's something which is ex helping you
experience and delve into the way in
which
identities exist
and that takes it takes all kinds of
forms in different uh in different uh
spheres but let's say in in a story it's
usually just like a a story has a basic
pattern usually which is something like
you have a beginning point you have a
problem and then you have a
resolution that's basically every single
story is something like that and then
you can play with that right you could
fail to have a resolution or you could
you could kind of play with it but
that's the basic pattern and so you can
realize that if that's what even even
like when you're telling that your day
to your spouse or to your friend that's
what you're doing you're saying here's
the start of the day here's a bunch of
stuff that happened and then i came back
home
the end right or you can make it smaller
but that's usually the way that pretty
much every single story we tell has that
pattern
okay
so
let me see so what does that mean like
yeah
why does that matter what is it like why
does it matter all right so the reason
why it matters is that you realize that
the way in which we interact with each
other is also like that
so the way that i interact the way that
we interact
like if i interact with you
there's a pattern to that
it's not arbitrary i can't just say
anything and i can't just do anything
there are certain things which bind our
interactions and that's true of a
conversation
it's true let's say let's say of a
family meal
right a family meal has a pattern
it doesn't it can't go anyway if you if
you do something crazy at the the dinner
table you'll ruin dinner right if you
throw your fork on the floor you ruined
dinner there's a million things you can
do to ruin dinner but we don't we're
able to to participate almost like a
dance
in this pattern and that scales up
so you can imagine like you have these
patterns your interactions with people
have these patterns your family dinner
your community
but that goes all the way up to
something that which would look like
religious rituals
that is that religious rituals once you
see that the world works that way
the idea of religion doesn't become it's
not silly anymore not only is it not
silly it's inevitable you realize that
the world actually laid itself out
through rituals and patterns and symbols
and stories and there's no way out of it
and that scales up to something which
would look like let's say for christians
would look like the mass or the liturgy
where we have a pattern of interaction
where we all
sing together we all look towards
something which is beyond us to unite us
together there's all this movement these
movements that we do that are not in any
way
superstitious or arbitrary but they're
completely coherent and they are the the
highest image of
you putting on your socks in the morning
right
anything you do
is pattern at least everything you do is
a play between a pattern and and let's
say the potential the the moment in
which you're playing like if you're
brushing your hair you don't brush your
hair in any way you have to brush your
hair in a certain way and there's
variability
but you can't if you if you brush your
hair with a with a knife it's not going
to work you're going to break the
pattern
so you have to so you realize that the
world is ritualized and patterned and
then what it helps at least i think it
helps us
reconnect to a bunch of stuff that
people have tossed out and have told us
is meaningless and stupid and
superstitious
um and it can help us it can help us
reconnect to those things in a i think
in a maybe a little more
more conscious way but a way that can
help solve the problem of
meaninglessness and disenchantment and
uh nihilism that is around us
okay
so
i'm gonna come back to that i'm gonna
have to sit on that for a bit i think
i've i had a weird experience i had a
crazy experience this
summer
where that's what i hear yeah yeah and
so that's why we're talking
is i got criticized because i said i
found god and apparently you're not
supposed to say that but
who said you're not supposed to say i
don't know people on the internet yeah
don't pay attention to the youtube
comments
uh
but
i think so you're talking about
so i think what did it for me was there
were too many i'm very i'd like to think
of myself as like logical very logical
so i've tried to put the world into
i've tried to understand the world
through science and
facts and
kind of devoid of intuition
and i think i learned that from my dad
and it took me a while to build back the
intuition side and to actually take that
seriously because i thought well if you
can't figure it out in your head then
it's not real which is completely
overestimating your ability to figure
things out
uh but i think this i think part of what
did it for me this summer was that
things
that was this pattern that you're
talking about right and i kind of
tuned into it like there well you know
what's been going on with my family it's
been completely absurd
but there have been things that have
happened that are just too weird to
explain any other way like when my mom
when mom was sick
she
it was like being in a movie like my
entire life has been being like being in
a movie which i you could say is like
being in a story but when my mom got
sick she knew the day she was gonna get
and it was like
well that's not yeah you can
literally can't explain that nobody
could explain it none of the doctors
could explain it and it was mom and
dad's anniversary
and so everybody in my family was just
kind of like huh
well put that in the pile of things we
just cannot understand at all so that
that occurrence
has just been like i've just been
thinking about that just being like how
do i understand that in a logical way
and then when my dad got sick so he he
was reacting to the medications he was
put on terribly
in that was january i thought
this is gonna be awful i had this weird
feeling like this is gonna be absolutely
awful absolutely awful for two years
right and i was like i can run away
because i was considering moving i was
like i could just
this is really difficult we didn't know
what to do this is really bad i was like
i could just run away or it's gonna take
two years and it's just gonna be like
crippling and i was like okay
i can do that this is two years right
out of a lifetime i can do two years and
then it was like
spot on
where things were really awful and then
everything just fixed themselves
and so those two things happened and
then there was just too many things like
that that happened that felt like i've
been i don't know living in a story
and so i don't know if that quote like
aligns with anything you said because
i'm having a difficult time exactly
understanding what you mean
but
does that make sense at all no it makes
sense i think that
i think that most people have these
moments and it's true that it often
happens
you can understand that that
this pattern of reality it's it's it's
it's actually reasonable but it always
points towards something which is a
little bit beyond itself like beyond
reason you could say so often we have
these crazy experiences we could call
them miracles or we could call them yeah
that revealed to us something which is a
little which is beyond
what's going on in everyday life like it
seems to kind of connect everything
together in a way that is very difficult
to fully account for
uh at the lower level uh and i think i
really believe that this is just this is
just how the world works like this is
not a
this is really how reality works like
reality is made with meaning like you
could say that a good way to understand
is that god really does fill up the
world and there are moments where we can
have these these things just
completely come together and you you
have a sense that not only a sense but
it's like your whole being is carried
off let's say for a moment and it
doesn't always last very long you know
some people last longer
you know thank goodness for them but for
most of us it's like a moment where you
feel carried up and you're like okay i
can't deny that like i can't deny what's
happened
um and so what is it that what was your
experience of saying that you found god
like what
like how did it how did it
like so you talk about your mom and
everything but in your life like what
did that mean like what did that mean in
terms of experience
well so that happened with my mom and
then
um she started practicing catholicism
right
and i thought that was very strange
because she got really into it really
quickly right from not being into it at
all kind of you know she's always had a
little bit she wanted us to go to church
a bit but it was never really part of
our family life it was like okay mom's
part of a cult and it looked like that
from the outside
it did even dad was little it wasn't
just catholicism it was some people
she was around and were like this looks
like a cult but
but
but she also started
becoming she became a lot more
empathetic and a lot more patient
and it was noticeable
and so i was talking to her about it and
just like how did you get there
she was like oh i you know god
like okay i don't understand that what
that means
uh and so it's been about
about a year
of me
being open to the idea but not
understanding what that meant or what
that felt like
and then in august
dad was dad was really sick in august
and it was really scary and too many bad
things were happening at the same time
it was like if things could go wrong
they were going wrong in every area
and i was like this is way too much this
is like
this doesn't make sense it's there's too
much bad luck happening at the same time
yeah so
um there was that i was navigating a
divorce
which was
bad but it was everything else was so
much worse that that was not even the
bad part of my life
so that
so it's just been brutal for a couple of
years
and and um i went away
for like a week um when when dad was a
bit he was a bit stable um but i needed
to just have a bit of time and i went
away and i met somebody who
was like how are you doing
and i was
because i had talked a bit about what i
was going through about my parents being
sick and like my job and the media and
dad and
divorce and everything and he was like
how are you holding up and i was like oh
i'm not holding up like i'm not holding
up i'm not depressed but i'm not holding
up things are awful right like i'm
crying every day but
it's not depression it's just things are
really bad
and he was like well you need god i was
like okay that's great that sounds
fantastic what do i do
and he said just
so this i don't even know how why this
happened exactly but he just said um
ask him to reveal himself to you
and i was like okay yeah i'll do that so
i went home and was like begged because
i was in rough shape i got to the point
this summer where things were so bad and
i couldn't do anything to to solve them
and i was like what do i do now if i've
tried every route
like every way possible to solve some of
these problems and there's nothing else
i can do what do i do and that's when i
started praying so i had to get to that
point and it took a while um but anyway
so i went home and so i was praying and
the next day
like a bunch of the all of the major
issues that i had
switched directions
so they didn't just go away but
things that i wanted to happen and i
could see happening but weren't
happening just all happened the same day
and i i was that was like that was it i
was like okay
so that was wild and then
oh well i've been reading the bible and
just trying to learn what i can um i had
some other
i had some other
strange experiences but
that's part of the reason i ha i'm
having you on because this is what he
knew even though dad is my dad like he
comes through this from a psychological
perspective and a meaning perspective
and
whatever i'm experiencing now isn't
exactly what he's taught me growing up i
think yeah
um
but it's it's it's related in a way like
it's related in the sense that
you know
i mean jordan
talks about the idea of of
going down into the the whale like
pinocchio going down or the father kind
of going down the dead father
you don't necessarily have to understand
it exactly in the sense of the death of
the father but you can understand it as
a world
that is an old world that's crumbling
let's say or something that all these
things that are kind of crumbling and
then
there's a sense in which
when the idea you you you hear this
about this alcoholic right it's like you
hit rock bottom right you've heard that
esthetics
expression but that doesn't necessarily
it's not something that happens just
with addiction something that can happen
in many ways but is it when we descend
and things start to break down it's very
painful but then what happens at the
bottom
is you get uh
you get something like
an inkling of a new world or something
like a light that appears in the in the
cavern
and
you know
and sometimes it can
this is people are gonna especially
scientifically minded people will find
this weird but sometimes the way that
you describe it is exactly right which
is that
you know things everything is going
wrong and then all of a sudden they
realign
yeah and realign right the idea of
finding meaning but it's not finding
meaning isn't just a subjective thing
that is meaning reveals itself to you
like things snap
and then it gives you a direction uh now
i mean obviously
this is what's in august so obviously
it's important to understand that that
won't necessarily last like that
experience
you know it's there to show you what's
possible
in your life and then later on you're
gonna have a lot of problems and it's
gonna it's gonna happen again like it's
even if you found god and you
let's say you kind of enter on that path
where you pray and you kind of try to
transform your life i mean it doesn't
mean that it's all going to be aligned
that way all the time it's more like
it's almost like an inkling of what's
possible is shown to you so you can
like like a glimmer to say like oh okay
this is it like i need to move in this
direction uh but then there's a lot more
pain you know along the way nonetheless
i actually when i so i'm on this like
meat diet right
when i
in 2015
when i went off of my medication and put
myself into remission and got better
that was the first time i didn't
associate it with god but that was the
first time when i could feel like i i
felt for my entire life that
i just was the embodiment of bad luck
somehow i was like why is it that
everything i do
i have to do four times
in order for it to kind of succeed
it was ridiculous and even my parents
commented on it they're just like things
work out for julian
but everything you do whatever could go
wrong goes wrong
and so i just lived my life like that it
was just like
it was awful it kind of got used to it
you never get used to that it's still
frustrating um and then i i got better
and i had that shift where it was just
like my world flipped upside down and i
associated with health i was just like
is this what it feels like to be healthy
but it was a really physical feeling of
going in the wrong direction and then
having things switch
and things were just working out i was
on time all the time like
if i missed an assignment there'd be a
delay and when it was due
it was things that didn't make sense
right and so that was the first time i
experienced that and then
i went off of my antidepressants those
were the last things i stopped taking
and i lost that
and then everything was awful again for
a number of years and i just had these
like so i it's been confusing because
i've been able to like logic
i've been able to think about it in a
logical way where i've been like well
this is what happened and that's why i
had those feelings so like i went off of
the ssris and i'd ssri withdrawal and
so i was depressed and not being
depressed is when i'm in this like
alignment
but then it's just gotten too weird and
i haven't been depressed for so long but
i've still had these feelings of being
in alignment or whatever that means or
going in the wrong direction and so now
now i'm a christian
so are you are you involved in a
community of some kind like are you
going
we're starting to so we've been to a
couple of churches
uh
i haven't found one that
clicked like the the thing that clicked
so dad came to visit
he's still here he's in nashville and
last sunday we went to it was actually
it was a gospel
kind of group of people
so they were singing in one of the bars
on broadway so that's what we did sunday
but that made me cry like they'd they'd
sing a song and then they talk a little
bit then they sing a song and talk a
little bit so there was something there
like
something there that really spoke to me
so we're just hopping around trying to
find a place mostly what i've been doing
is praying and reading the bible
um
yeah
wow i mean i mean it's i think it's i
can see in your eyes like just how
like how kind of confusing wide-eyed you
are which is which is actually pretty
wonderful to to to see that uh
you know i think that you'd
how can i say this like there is also a
sense in which
th
how can i say this it's like
at least what you're describing you seem
to have these extremes you know and i
think
yeah jordan majorly has has a little bit
of that too it's like the
and so
you have to be a little i mean you
definitely have to be a little careful
because it's it's almost like uh like
imagine a um
someone who's manic depressive like
someone who has a bipolar you know
someone who's bipolar but it's not this
there's other types of bipolarity that
aren't just psychological that is there
are people whose lives are bipolar you
could say you can see and so you you if
you're attentive to that you can maybe
uh also try to moderate it a bit and
also try not to ride the
when you're up and you're aligned try to
be careful not to ride it too high
because
that's not that's also that's all it's
also not necessarily the best
way to go if if that makes sense to you
because because that leads to another
down
i don't know if if you i i don't know
how else to explain it to you that's
going to be harder to for me to explain
which is does it have to lead to another
down no because it doesn't feel like
it's going to happen
i think i think the best thing to do is
to i mean the best thing is to try to
moderate
the experience like moderate your
direction you could say
um but i don't like it it's hard to
explain because it's very existential um
but it's like if you if you if you get
that alignment and you start to write it
and you become
and everything's perfect and you become
you can imagine it this way like
everything's perfect and everything's
going well and it's like
yeah a good way to a good christian way
to explain it would be that then you
forget to pray like that would be a good
way to a christian way to explain it is
that you you get that alignment and then
you start going up the hill and it's
like everything's good and everything
fine and everything's working and it
feels like you're on top of the world um
and then you forget to pray because
you pray when you're at the bottom
because because you're suffering because
that's why you pray when you're down
there and so it's like when you're
growing up then you stop praying because
you're going up
and that's the danger so the idea so you
could say something like moderating the
experience with
with prayer
and worship is is part of it where
you're
you give up you you're giving up
your success and what you're doing up to
something above you so that it doesn't
it says so that it doesn't carry you too
high
okay i think
and i don't want to like be boastful or
anything but i i'm hoping that i've been
walloped enough times
that when things are when things are
good
i don't get used to that it's shocking
like this is completely different than
anything i've experienced and there's no
way that this was me
right so i think i'm hoping i can stay
um like humble during those experiences
because because and i i i think maybe
well i think that's also partly what
brought me to where i am now because the
good experiences were also totally
unbelievable yeah whereas like things
can be so bad it doesn't make sense but
they're also so good that it didn't make
sense too so that's not me
well i think it actually is you it seems
that that's actually you like you seem
to at least the way you're describing to
me you seem to attract extremes uh
and so
it's it's bound to if you extract it if
you attract the extreme in one direction
there's a there's a high chance that
you'll attract it in the other direction
too
you know um and so that's why i guess
that's why i said just to be careful but
i think it's i think it's wonderful i
mean
i think it's great that that you
that you have that experience and that
you're also
acting on it right
uh
because you could have just left it and
said oh okay here's this experience
and then move on with your life now yeah
no it was like thank you to do that
there's no way yeah
and so are you able to talk about it
with with your family
yeah i mean i talked about it like i
said when the first time when i i
thought felt things aligned i associated
it with a switch in health and that is
part of why i was feeling better but it
it was like on another level
uh and i talked to my family about it
and then when i there's some other weird
things that have happened
when i went
but that i've also been able to say well
maybe it was because of this so when i
um went off of ssris i had ssri
withdrawal and i got sensitive to light
and sound and like touch and
um
and carbs
so like sugars and chemicals it was
awful and it lasted for about two and a
half years really intensely
but the first time i had a severe
reaction i talked about this on rogan i
was like i had a whole bunch of soy and
my body was really unhappy with it and i
got itchy
my digestion was upset and i got
arthritis i got mouth ulcers like my
whole body was very very angry my skin
broke out
and two and a half days later i
hallucinated a demon
on my brother
and
i was like okay you know that happened i
was like okay that
that looked real it was like one and a
half seconds long so it wasn't just a
flash it was like i looked it looked at
me and then looked away
and
i tried not to have a panic attack
and
was like okay i've gone off of my
medications and now i'm crazy like great
that's that's the most logical
explanation here it was like no it seems
to coincide with this soy reintroduction
it's some sort of inflammatory response
like whatever
but i had similar experiences with like
faces really terrifying like teeth
faces
off and on for about a year every time i
tried to reintroduce a food that my body
didn't like i'd have a like full-blown
autoimmune response and i'd start seeing
these like demon faces
but i just thought okay that's the
representation of what people are most
scared of like a predator
and so when i'm having these depressive
reactions which are an autoimmune
response
and my body starts panicking then it's
putting something there
that's scary to kind of justify how i'm
feeling yeah so that that's what i
thought but then after you know that
happens ten times and then a whole bunch
of other weird things happen
at some point you're like well
are they demons maybe like i don't know
what's going on so
i mean okay so i don't know jonathan
maybe i don't know what's real anymore
let me mess with you a little more if
you don't mind with your mind a little
bit so
the the mechanical cause cause
of these things that is like you say i
took this food i i you know i had this
thing something could be like i didn't
sleep enough or yeah whatever like the
mechanical causes
doesn't
doesn't uh take away
from the meaning
of the experience
right and so
you saw like you said you saw a demon
and so there is a maybe a mechanical
cause for the reason why you see a demon
but the demon you see you recognize it
as a demon
but you didn't see a flower you didn't
see
a watermelon you saw a demon and so
that's a real thing
right the the type of image that we
associate with demons are real
they they're objective you they're not
uh they're not arbitrary and they have
to do like you said with uh with
monstrosity they have to do with
evil intention they have to do with all
these things now
what i would say what i would say to you
is of course you have to be careful not
to let yourself get sucked into that
because
even even if you read science or if you
read uh ascetics or if you read kind of
holy people right they'll tell you not
to be seduced let's say by by this these
kind of demonic apparitions but it
doesn't mean that they're that they're
ju yeah when anybody tells you like it's
just a hallucination yeah that these are
those are meaningless words
because the the just what is this just
you see something and it has meaning
and so you have to be able to engage it
that way and then deal with it that way
you know and so
um and it's the same with all the other
things you have to happen to like let's
say you start to see positive things
happen to you
and so you say well i could explain the
causality of all the positive things
happening to me but you're still able to
see and experience and participate in
these positive things that are happening
to you
and that's objectively taking you out of
your rut let's say
and so the idea that let's say the idea
that these meaningful things happen to
you that something comes from heaven is
a good way to say it like there's
something coming down to you from heaven
uh doesn't at all contradict the
it has nothing to do with the mechanical
causalities
i don't know if it's hard to explain it
this way it's like
um
so so let's say you see these demons
right so you see these demons what what
could seeing these demons
do
to you
well it could make you scare you stop
you're terrified terrifying it was
terrifying and it stopped me from
you
i don't even i don't even know what the
purpose of that was like
i have no idea scaring you scaring you
is is is enough
how can i say that scaring you is enough
because you you see what's ex you see
what's possible let's say
that is that is you
could become that and you probably know
that
that that or the people
the world around you could become that
yeah with what you're seeing in that
hallucination the world could become
that it's a it's you know it's an
imagistic version of something which is
which exists like you said this this
this evil that's in you that's in others
that's around us you perceive it it's
it's a real thing and so the idea that
it would scare you
is enough
scary enough to say i don't
want that
i this this sounds like the dumbest
thing that someone could say but it's
it's it's if you
if you take just a moment to understand
it you'll see that it's actually quite
uh it's it's actually quite meaningful
to say i don't want that and and and to
to start to
to make little movements little gestures
towards prayer you could say
so that you
so that you can be
realigned
i don't that makes sense it's hard to
talk about stuff in a way especially for
like more scientifically-minded people
to understand but
i try
no this is good this is good i can see
why you and my dad are talking because
he's more scientifically minded but
you're not
as far
over to whatever the other side is as
some people are
well i try to bridge i try to bridge the
story world and and a more something
which is compatible with psychology
you're compatible with a lot of the way
people think today uh but like when
someone
like if someone tells you like a a very
kind of literalist uneducated person
tells you like don't do that you'll go
to hell
they're they're usually telling the
truth
but it's usually true that if you engage
in certain it depends sometimes they can
get they can get it wrong in the details
but there are things you can do
and there are ways you can be
and there are ways you can engage with
others that will
tend you towards hell you could say
where you will have worse experiences
um
and then there are ways to be and ways
to engage with others which will
bring you up
um and so not everybody is a not
everybody has those experiences more
immediately the way that you
had
which is like seeing demons and then
seeing miracles like a lot of people
don't have those experiences you know
but they're possible they're definitely
possible and they feed the imagistic
world they feed
right the stuff the thing you saw when
you saw someone like when you saw a
demon appear let's say
that's i mean that's what horror movies
are made of they're made of those
experiences people have those
experiences they're real they're
and then they make stories out of them
but
yeah
so i wouldn't be too freaked out about
it because
there are some people that are more
sensitive to these kinds of experiences
but it usually means that you might be
more sensitive to the higher experiences
too like you might have
more let's say
elated experiences uh ahead of you
possibly
well that seems that seems to be true
hopefully more than the demon
experiences those are unpleasant so why
if there are ways you can act in order
to align yourself properly i guess we
could
speak like that something like that
why would
those kind of bad experiences like and a
more hellish version of life exist for
children
if they're like what what's with that
yeah
what i'm going to say is going to be uh
it's hard because i don't want to
diminish suffering
uh but
so
let's take you
because i'm talking to you
that i could say i could tell you
that without
that
you wouldn't have had that it's that
expense
so it just takes time
it's just that suffering
is
suffering
is can become
uh
for some if if you're able to
align it like if you're able to embody
it properly suffering can become an
opportunity for transformation and an
opportunity for something
which is uh
higher you could say and so that's why
that's actually one of the differences
between the way christians
tend to see
disability or or suffering uh compared
to some other traditions which is that
we there's a story you know where christ
heals a blind person and
people ask him like why is he blind is
it because his parents sinned is it
because he sinned like yeah what evil
happened so that this person be blind
and christ
heals him but his answer is even more
important he says
no this person is blind
to show the glory of god
that is that
there's something about suffering that
it can be transformed into
into something greater
um
you know and i think like i remember uh
i remember jordan
having an intuition of that once when we
were in montreal and we were going to
see the uh the totem pole uh that was uh
put up by his his uh his brother you
know
and uh and he he said that that he had
suffered quite a bit
and that that suffering had been refined
into gold and that's what his art was
basically
and so i was like jordan charles was
just someone who said that
jordan said that about trump oh
wow yeah he said he said his suffering
he suffered a lot like he really
suffered but that that suffering
has been kind of transformed into beauty
transformed into
something that is higher and so not
everybody's an artist but you can you
can see
um
if you've met people that have suffered
a lot and i'm someone who actually
hasn't suffered much but like if you
meet people that have suffered a lot and
they
have um
suffered
well i don't know how to say it or
suffered in a way that is like a yes i
don't know how like a
they tend to
have a specific magic about them which
is hard to describe right they tend to
have a kind of
glory
a kind of a kind of uh
something about them which is hard to
which which transcends
the normal world and so i think that
that's
you know it's not that god causes
suffering is that is that suffering
you know the christian way to describe
that suffering is part and parcel of the
world of the fall right and that in the
world of the fall suffering is is our
is the thing we need to deal with but
that god is able to transform suffering
into
something else
and that's what that's what the cross is
like that's what jesus on the cross
means
that that it's god transforming
suffering into something
which is more
um
so but it's hard to talk about because
it's like i don't i don't want people to
think that i'm trying to to delegitimize
suffering or i'm trying to diminish uh
this type of suffering that people live
but i think that
i at least in my experience when i met
people that have suffered
and have
endured or transcended they are
way more
um
than people that haven't
i would say also if like i've suffered
quite a bit
and i think the only way this was before
any type of christianity how i kind of
figured it out and i thought the only
way that that could be worth it whatever
worth it means
um would be if other people don't have
to experience it right if if i just
quantified it and i could help other
people not experience that then it would
even out it'd be like
whatever that meant and so that that's
how i kind of figured it out
yeah
that's a great way to understand it and
you can see it like at many many levels
where you know
like who's the person helping out
alcoholics the most
he's always an ex-alcoholic right who's
the person helping uh
you know abuse victims who's the person
helping people who suffer it's usually
someone who has suffered and so there's
a way that you can see that like it
really is this image of of transforming
suffering into blessing transforming
suffering into something else
which is actually
manifesting the
the compassion uh god's compassion in
the world through all through us right
we always think that we always ask
ourselves like why is god doing this or
why is god not doing this and the answer
is we are the body
like we are the body of the of the the
divine in the world we are the hands and
feet and the
of god and so it's through us that those
things happen
so that's that's i think that that's
that's the best way to see it
why do you think these then i don't know
if anybody can actually answer these
questions but why is it that some people
can
i i guess like come to god
so easily compared to other people
like i feel like i had to see some crazy
things before i was like okay that makes
sense
but some people are just like no i've
believed it since i was a kid and i know
you can grow up in families that believe
but not everybody in a family that
believes grows up and believes but why
do you think that some people
are just like yep not makes sense
and other people are like there's you
just don't get it at all
no no i don't know how to i'd have
totally answered that question you know
uh
like i i think i mean it i think there's
probably a whole host of reasons like
all a whole
host of uh
and so
especially it's it's
i think that it's mostly true that what
you're saying is mostly true now like
it's you know it's not i don't think it
would have been so true in a world where
most people were christian this is it's
kind of weirdly true in a world that's
very atheistic and kind of very secular
where people
uh
somehow think that they're living
outside of this pattern that we
described and but they're wrong right
and they think that they're living
outside of it uh in a more normal world
people would always know that they're
kind of inside this giant
let's say pattern that's moving up
towards the infinite but but for us we
tend to be think that we can live
outside it and so
so i think that it all it is also like a
man it's it's has something to do with
the modern world it has something to do
with our kind of secular world where
but i think that world is ending really
yeah by the way
i think so too yeah
yeah like we're on a cusp of of like
major transformations in terms of how
the religious is pouring back into
reality
and uh
yeah and it's it's it's i it's something
that it's something that i intuited a
while ago
and
and and to be honest like i i intuited
that your dad was gonna participate in
that and so this fight himself despite
not being a particularly religious
person himself like it's pretty much
playing itself out uh but it's also
playing itself out for ill like it's not
only for good there's a lot of the
religious things uh seeping back in that
are pretty dark
and so you can see like in the in a lot
of the kobit stuff there's a lot of
religious religiosity
in the way that people deal with with
kovid in the way that people deal with
woke culture it's becoming more and more
religious
in its instantiations and so
uh so it's so i would say like
re-enchantment is kind of happening for
the for the dark and the and the light
part of it um
hopefully we can participate in the
light part of it
yeah
wow
that's wild i think you're right though
i mean if you intuited that like around
you notice that all of a sudden people
all these people are suddenly
people who never could have even thought
about
god or religion or prayer and all of a
sudden
it's like it's all of a sudden it's
possible like the things that i'm
telling you
10 years ago no one would have even
understood what i was talking about
a lot of the stuff that we're now able
to talk about it just would have been
completely gibberish yeah
the dawkins type 10 years ago and so now
all of a sudden this whole world is
opened up and then you you realize you
see all these people you know just
all of a sudden it just becomes obvious
that they need to have some kind of
religious
practice they need to be connected to
community they need to be connected to
something higher than themselves so
yeah that's wild okay i have i had a
list of questions we didn't get to any
of them
but one of the things i've been so i've
been reading the bible and praying and
being and
also kind of trying to research because
i don't really know any of the
background on christianity or what the
difference between
catholics and protestants are i was just
like i know you know catholics have the
pope like i'm really starting from
their base level pretty much base level
yeah is it googling what's the
difference between all the different
denominations and and all that
so
dad told me uh that you
grew up
in a catholic family but switched to
orthodoxy i grew up in a in a protestant
like a baptist
evangelical family and then i became
orthodox yeah okay so what what's the
difference between those two what does
orthodox mean
what is orthodoxy
so i don't i want to be careful not i
want to try not to offend too many
people because obviously this becomes
prickly when you start trying to
describe what other people believe
and so um
so orthodoxy
is more uh ritualized you could say
and so it's more like a catholic church
if you if you would go into an orthodox
church for example it's singing the
whole time
and uh you know the the priests have
vestments that are symbolic
the there are paintings on the walls
that are symbolic they're everything
they do is almost like a a dance
of a worshipful dance you could say
and uh so that's in terms of experience
that's what you would probably see the
difference when you walked into an
orthodox church there would be icons
there would be
there'd be sensors there'd be like
smoke rising up with like with like uh
smells and the candles so it's like it
has this kind of ritual embodied aspect
and evangelicals and protestants are
more
informal they tend to
emphasize the informal more right like
uh
god
you know i can talk to god anytime i
want i can you know it's like god jesus
is my friend that type of way of of
seeing it where you know and it's more
testimonies and
so so it's in the experience that's
usually for someone who doesn't know
anything about let's say the differences
that's how you would probably experience
the difference
um so let's say uh
evangelicals and kind of protestants
tend to emphasize uh
personal experience personal testimony
um story you know uh
the idea of uh
sin also right like god saved me from my
sins
uh whereas in the orthodox in the
orthodox tradition um
it's more about it's
more about this kind of coming together
and worship and participating in
something that is beyond you and
becoming let's say the body of christ in
that way so that's the that's the
experience but then in terms of
a bunch of stuff like i'm sure you don't
you don't necessarily want to get into
that to that right away but you
i mean at some point it's i think you
just need to move slowly and at some
point you'll start to to kind of see and
understand
the differences let's say
i don't like moving slowly in regards to
anything
well then you can read books like it's
probably better to read books than to go
online too much because man on the
online okay
it's a mess okay
do you have
book suggestions then and i also after
this i want to ask you
what the difference between catholicism
is and why is it that protestants don't
believe some of the catholic books i
have so many questions but first
hey there sorry to interrupt the episode
but
i stay working because of these ads
and i love schwank grills you probably
know i'm very experienced at cooking
meat because of my diet so i really know
what i'm talking about to put it bluntly
schwein grills are some of the best in
the market shrank's heating technology
has been used by the world's best steak
houses since the 1980s these portable
american-made grills reach 1500 degrees
fahrenheit without smoking are super
easy to clean and get you high quality
steakhouse worthy steaks in about three
minutes
you know when it's crispy but medium
rare and juicy underneath
mired reactions if you want to sound
fancy
but it's not just steaks you can make
just about anything on these grills
chicken hamburgers veggies it's even got
a pizza stone for pizza eaters which
applies to most people i realize head to
schweinkgrills.com today and get 150 off
a schwank 1500 degree grill when using
promo code mp at checkout again that's a
hundred and fifty dollars off
over at schwank grills that's
s c h w a n k grills dot com with code
mp at checkout everything's in the
description linked
enjoy the rest of the episode
what what book should i read
uh well it depends for what like what do
you what would you want to to to
understand like let's say what are you
looking for
i think i'd probably be interested in
understanding how
people connect with god how people think
they connect with god because you just
said there's differences between say
orthodoxy and protestants and i think
what i'm more familiar with is
protestantism i think that's what i'm
thinking that's what you must know and
so
the orthodox tradition the catholic
church the orthodox even more so is more
it's more mystical
it it doesn't tend to talk about
our interaction with god in a manner
that is um
that's like a conversation it's like i'm
talking to god
and then you have these answers in your
life uh your orthodoxy tends to have
this notion that you need to be
transformed and you you kind of uh
you become god by participation you you
know through prayer through certain
types of of uh to asceticism through
trying to kind of remove yourself from
your passions then you actually are
transformed into something more than
yourself
um and so that's a little bit of a
difference in terms of let's say the way
that people connect with god and it's
gonna look differently it's gonna look
differently so so that's why there'll be
less
in in the kind of especially the modern
evangelical services
you know the let's say the the songs
they sound like pop songs they sound
like love song basically but they're
they talk about god
like if they would in a pop song
and that's something that you wouldn't
find today in a in the catholic church
or the orthodox church where there's
more this reverence and the sense of
you know that god is really uh is is is
beyond us and is above us and is
bringing us up into him you know
something like that um i know people in
the youtube comments are gonna get super
annoyed with the way i'm describing this
because you know everybody it's like
it's that's why i said it's hard to talk
about what other people's uh other
people saying but i can send you like
there's a book called uh called the it's
in terms of orthodoxy there's a little
book called the orthodox way which is a
a not very long uh and it's a book that
kind of explains
um
this kind of mystical approach to to to
the faith
you know and how it connects to to us
today um so
so yeah you can look that up i can send
you a link if you want okay that would
be good i've just i've been talking to
some i've been talking to like very lots
of people about this and i'll come
across people and they'll be you know
different denominations or catholic or
you know something and they'll be like
oh no this is the way
this is the way because of you know x
yeah so there's an overlapping thing but
yeah i'm trying to not go into theology
too much with you just because it's like
i think i really dislike i dislike
arguing about religion i would rather
try to help you i'd rather give you ways
to kind of see the the beauty of the
christian tradition and the beauty
that's there um
but there are other people who
definitely try to convince you so yeah
there's got to be some good like uh some
i mean what even the differences you
just described
couldn't and couldn't it be some could
it be both
yeah could it not yeah definitely but it
tends it i'm just giving you kind of
basic uh
let's say basic directions you could say
and so the
let's say that the protestant the
protestant church is really a
fruit of the modern world like it's
it's it has it's very modern in
everything that about it the way that it
it understands god the way that it
understands uh the world the way that it
the way that it does worship all of this
is very modern whereas let's say the
catholic church and the orthodox church
they are more
they're kind of like a stream which
comes down from millennia
and the sense of connection
between
all these different generations and that
we can receive what is uh behind before
us and this kind of participation in the
stream so that will definitely affect
uh
everything about it so right so the
catholic and
the orthodox especially like they'll
talk about the fourth century as if
they're still there they'll talk about
the 10th century as if they're still
there for them all of this is part of
their experience like all of these all
of these great uh christians that have
really showed us god and have manifested
love and and and god in the world we see
them as kind of our ancestors that we
that we that we continue their their
their story
um and so that will definitely whereas
the the evangelical protestant will say
how can we adapt christianity
how can we reach out to people right
it's like we want to do it in a way that
people will understand and so they'll
tend to adapt
christianity to popular forms that's why
it sounds like that's why it's a concert
that's why it's
it's it's jazzy or it's you know it's
like it looks like something you would
see at a show because they're more
focused on
how can we adapt this to
to people and to the modern world
so it's just different it really
definitely different approaches
hmm
interesting okay
what you should probably do is you
should probably
go physically
let's say to a catholic church and then
go physically to find an orthodox church
in english and go and then go to an
evangelical church like take give
yourself a few months
to
to see because it's because it's uh we
can talk about it but
it's not the same as going and having
the experience of the of the space and
the people and the
the type of worship and the type of uh
that's got to be super dependent on the
church though right i know i've i've
been to i remember this was before i'd
i don't even know what you call it what
do you call it tuned in like yeah
this is before i tuned in yeah went to a
couple of
um
church services with my mom
and i was little so maybe i was just too
little to be like be able to pay
attention but i remember just like i was
that was not for me at all
it was like this is like one of them i
think was catholic and i was just like
there's just
i'm just there's nothing of that speaks
to me at all there's somebody talking i
don't understand there's no emotion
right
so i think wouldn't that be very
dependent on where you'd go like there
there must be better
oh for sure i mean i'm sure they're
better versions of every single type of
church that's that's for certain uh but
in general you'll still have a basic
uh experience of the difference so for
example like if you for sure if you go
to a liturgical church like a church
that has a more ritualized form then
there'll be less
um extreme emotion
that's for sure like 100 it'll be more
contemplative it'll be more kind of this
this standing in silence you know and
kind of contemplating the mystery you
know kind of approaching uh slowly and
also being attentive to your thoughts
trying to to kind of move in you know
and not be distracted all of that is the
type of experience you'll have
if you go to a more
like it's a more
modern evangelical type church then
it'll be way more emotional because then
you'll have a pop singer a guy with a
guitar
it'll be a rock concert it'll be it'll
be uh you know a really
um
a really dynamic speaker that's gonna be
super
uh involved and so
yeah it really does uh
it it there is a difference for sure
but then for or you said orthodoxy was
more spiritual
right i think so i think that it's more
spirit it's more mystical for sure it
has this mystical it has it it's it it
has this idea that you're to be
transformed through attention through uh
discipline through
um through prayer through uh
you know and and i mean of course also
the love of others like all of this kind
of is this
symphony but if you go to an orthodox
church and you're expecting to be
entertained it's not going to happen
like it's not you're not going to be
entertained it's not meant to be
entertaining it's meant to
make it's meant to ask you to make us
someh some
a little bit of an effort in order to be
attentive and a little bit of an effort
in order to participate you know um and
so for example like in a lot of orthodox
churches there are no benches you can't
sit
you're not supposed to relax
you're supposed to be there and try to
be attentive and to kind of be present
rather than sit back and
enjoy you know those are different
stances
um
and then or okay so um protestants too
probably
the protestants are so big like presents
are so the thing is i want to be careful
because like i'm not when i say the way
i'm talking about protestants is really
like modern evangelical churches that
you'll probably find mostly in where you
are in tennessee but there are some
products in churches that are not like
that that are more formal that are more
uh ritualized that have more structure
so it really depends yeah crosston
church is like once once the the pro the
reformation happened it's like scattered
into
thousands and thousands of little
denominations it was like a
it's like a thing falling on the ground
and just
exploding into like thousands of
denominations so so it's hard to talk
about protestantism as one thing it's
like
thousands of things
okay
uh so
it's been an hour and i could
talk for a very long time because i have
a whole bunch more questions but maybe
it's up to you i'm i don't i like you
for a little bit longer yeah i am free
so yeah we could go keep going okay cool
let's talk a little bit longer then
okay
reformation
let's start with that what exactly
happened there and i've looked at this
before but yeah can you describe what no
this is like you're no but that's fine
very much i'll mostly try not to be
polemical because it's hard okay because
i have my perspective on the reformation
and so
the the reformation is
so the church let's say the the
christian church is is an institution
right it's a it's a human institution
supposed to serve god but sometimes
often it doesn't and so it tends to it
tends to towards the the it tends down
let's say
so
so things get bad people get corrupt
people start doing weird stuff and then
usually there's a wake up
a reformation a little a little
reformation and then it it it gets
re-realigned you could say and so in the
the history of the catholic church in
the west there are many of these reforms
before the reformation right there's the
gregorian reform there's a there's the
there's a cluniac the kind of cluniak
reform there's these different like
different reforms that happen where
people are trying to like bring people
back to the to the good stuff instead of
the corruption and the chaos and so
during during a certain time there was a
lot of corruption and a lot of bad stuff
happening and then a monk
uh protested against that
corruption
and this time
it was different because this time
when because the church will will tend
to censor those people like if someone
tries to rock the boat they'll be like
you know stop rocking the boat and so
luther was censored by the church said
no you're wrong and they started arguing
with him and usually what happens will
be arguments and arguments and then
at some point the church will say you
can't stop stop saying what you're
saying you know and then there might be
consequences if they don't um but luther
aligned himself with princes in germany
and then was able to
separate himself
from the catholic church
so that's the difference you said
printers
no
with princes with like oh princess yeah
princess so princess so different uh
state
state actors in germany were were and so
he was able to
separate himself from the church and
then what happened is
that started to accelerate
and so they
they started to
different reformers started to say their
own thing and they were fighting amongst
reformers as well
and a lot of it had to do with the idea
of salvation by grace
alone
which is the idea that you're not saved
by works
so it's not what you do that saves you
it's it's a it's something it's a gift
from god you get you get the gr god
gives you salvation basically
and then then the then the reformers
started to argue amongst themselves
and they also was also like a real bible
emphasis so sola scriptura
right sola fide sola gracia so it's like
you're saved by faith alone you're saved
by grace alone that is that it's god
that saves you
and it happens through the means of
trust in god and faith
and then
the testimony of that is in the bible
the bible is the highest
okay let's say the highest revelation of
god in the world or the revelation of
god in the world it's like the ultimate
authority
so you can't go against the bible the
bible is the ultimate authority in the
world
and so that let's say that's the basis
of the reformation you could say but
then the reformers start to argue
and then there starts to be state
churches
and that's that's that's the play out of
the reformation
is that some princes also use the
reformation as a political tool
to
uh separate themselves and control the
church then you have the church of
england
who the that that or for for who the
head of the church is the
king and then you have the different
churches
different national churches that have
become state churches where the priests
are actually state employees basically
right and then out of that you have
people say no no that wasn't the point
of the reformation you can't have
state churches like you that's not that
wasn't the point of what we're doing and
so they become more radical and they're
like no we need to separate
to separate from that and then you have
puritans and anabaptists and people who
are like no we don't want these state
churches we just want to be the body of
god and to be these churches and so they
start to separate and then it's then
they fight amongst each other then they
separate and they fight amongst each
other and they separate and then at some
point you have 10 000
denominations of christians right and so
so the reformat that's basically you
could say the story of the reformation
okay is there so where you are you'll
meet mostly people that are children of
the reformation
yeah
okay where was i going with this next
it's a lot to think about
so i tried to be very objective i do not
agree with the reformation like i think
the right i could stay
i'm sure you could discern it but i
tried to be for all the protestants
watching this i tried to be as objective
as i could be without
without pretending that i agree with it
i don't think the reformation was good
okay why don't you think the reformation
was good
um there are a few things like the one
is the one is the mess
that was already kind of there
right and so the idea that
salvation is something that you can
either win through works
or that you could get freely through
grace
is already a problem like that's already
a problem so when you start to argue
that way it's like how many good things
can i do to be saved
or then oh no i can do enough good
things to be saved
so god has to save me because i can't do
enough good things to be saved right so
it's like this it's like a moralistic
system it's like a moralistic system
where you it's like a where you do good
to please god it's like you have this
daddy and his daddy wants you to do good
thing but you can't and so he's like you
can't do the good things that you need
to be in my
in my my
my world and so what i'll do is i'll
give it to you like i'll i'll bring you
know yeah
it's an act of grace right and so
to me that's the problem so the problem
of the reformation is was was a deeper
problem was already a problem that was
there in europe at the time where it was
this this legalistic kind of arbitrary
idea of doing good things to be good
enough to go to heaven and so
and so that's why so i think the
reformation is a problem but it was not
just the reformation the church the
catholic church itself was in a in a
tough
place because they had already set up
this weird legal system it's like weird
legal system of like
you know like the idea for example that
if you do so many bad things and you go
to purgatory for so many years and then
you have to say you have to do so many
things to like to to reduce the number
of years
in purgatory
where did that come from is that that's
not in the bible somewhere right no it
well it comes from the idea that it
comes from it comes it's a it's a um
how can i say this it's a side effect of
this kind of legal way of thinking about
salvation
right it's a it's a side effect of yeah
can you explain that
if it's not in the bible in the first
place
well see this that's
again one of the problems that happens
is that the idea that the bible is this
is the
is the only source of
of reality let's say or only source of
truth that's something that the
reformers oh so what's what's on the
other side
the reformers say like if it's not in
the bible it's not true and then and
then it's like okay so
but that's not that wasn't the standard
before now i don't want to defend the
the way that the catholics uh had their
notion of purgatory i'm not catholic so
i i don't feel like i have to defend
that but the idea that if it's not in
the bible then it's not real it's just
so where's all the other information
then
so the way let's say the way that the
more traditional churches understand it
and the way that the catholic and the
orthodox understand it is that the
church is a body of people
but the church is in a book
god is in a book
the bible isn't the word of god
jesus christ is the word of god it's the
manifestation of the divine logos of god
in the world that's the word of god the
bible is super important
like the bible is is a is a good means
to help to prevent yourself from going
into
into chaos let's say um but it's but the
the reality is more
linked to the actual body of people and
let's say their connection to
to christ through
generations of people that
transmit not just a bunch of books but a
way of being and a way of praying and a
way of seeing god in a way of engaging
with god so that's the way the
traditional churches understand it that
there's a transmission right more like
like
your father can write you a letter
and that's good
but he won't contain his being in the
letter it'll be in his example
the example that you get like you must
you let's say you you model your life on
his example and so if he writes a letter
to say you should do this you do that
it's like that's great i'll keep it it's
great advice
but the higher thing is the model and so
that's the way that the traditional
church understood it so it's like they
have traditions which flow down from the
apostles
into the into the church okay so it's a
different way of of of seeing it but the
biggest important thing is that for
example in the in the more mystical way
of understanding christianity it's like
it's not about doing good things to go
to heaven it's never it was never about
that and it was never about not being
able to do enough good things in order
to go to heaven it's about
becoming something
that you become
heaven you could say
you're transformed into something that's
free
and that's
going up the mountain or moving up
towards something higher so it's more
about so so the idea that let's say you
shouldn't lie
isn't about like well if i lie so many
times and i'll have so many years in
purgatory or whatever it's about if you
lie
you are destroying yourself and you're
destroying the world around you
if you tell the truth then you're
building yourself and you're building
the world around you and that will
transform you into something
more than what you were before
and so the christian life
now doesn't become a bunch of stuff you
have to do
it becomes a bunch of ways you have to
be
in order to be transformed transformed
into something more so that's that's
more the mystical and i think it's the
more the original way of understanding
christianity so what by the time you
come to the argument of like can i do
enough things to please god or not
please god it's like it's all arbitrary
it's like that's not the idea the idea
is that
you're becoming in the image of christ
by embodying these patterns by embodying
this way of being by putting your
attention towards god above you by by
putting your energy and your attention
towards the things that transcend you
you're being transformed into
the the thing that you're focusing on
you're slowly becoming in the image of
christ
okay so that sounds a lot like what my
dad teaches
sounds that's why everybody's jokes
about jordan and says that he's like
he's like a pre-orthodox like he he
that's why there's so many orthodox have
connected to what he said is that you
know although there's a lot of things
that he said that they don't agree with
but in terms of just the basic trope of
of transformation and of understanding
uh the way the world kind of we will
participate in the world it's much
closer to orthodox uh
let's say way of of being
okay so then my my one question and then
we should wrap it up my one my last
question i think would be
so if protestants are you know the bible
is
the most important thing word of god
they've got that
and you're saying that it's this
tradition
how do people who are joining know that
the tradition they're seeing in
orthodoxy is real
well usually i mean it's the testimony
of the of the saints that is it's the
it's the glowing examples of people
who
shy
right and so we have we have all these
testimonies all these
these stories of people that are bright
that are amazing that are just beyond
the normal human
um way of
seeing and so they they kind of are
fruits of this body they're the fruits
of this of this of this process um
and i think
that's the most existential way
but they're all you could also do it we
could also argue in terms of theology
and metaphysics and all that and some
people love doing that you'll find them
all around i don't tend to think that
way i do also think that they're like we
could argue about it in terms of even in
terms of biblical interpretation that we
could argue but i think that ultimately
that's
that's closer to
what
uh
what i think is
the the living the life of the of the
church
is that it's you have these these fruits
that appear that are these bright bright
bright lights and and they kind of help
you see what's possible and you kind of
see in the saints that oh wow there's
something some people can be more than
what i am
you know and that that that gives you
hope and it gives you models to uh to
kind of move
okay that that part makes sense to me i
think the part that i'd be concerned
with is joining a church that has gone
sideways that like isn't what it appears
under the eyes of orthodoxy or under the
guise of cath catholicism or something i
don't know if that's me being paranoid
but i like how do you is there a way to
feel it out to make sure that the
direction you're going is in alignment
yeah i mean i can't i can't i can't uh i
can't be like i can't be in your
experience that's why i i said a good
idea would be maybe to kind of have have
those experiences you know and there's
also a difference
between
the local
experience of something also literally
the local instantiation of something and
then the bigger frame in which it exists
so so for example the the the catholic
tradition or the orthodox tradition they
have
bad priests and you'll have find bad
priests and bad parishes and people that
are corrupt they're everywhere in the
world
but
but nonetheless there is something which
is let's say
there's something unified and something
real that happens and the same thing if
you go to prosecutors like you can go to
processing shirt that is completely
pathological like that can happen you
know uh so i mean i think you're
i i think you're you have a
like your you're low low enough on
agreeableness that you're not the kind
of person that's in danger of falling
into a cult at least that's my
impression i might be i might be wrong
but no i don't i hope not anyway
i'd be more likely to start a cult
i'm just kidding i'm not gonna do that
that sounds about that's not right so i
would say don't don't do that don't
start
don't start like go to an actual church
and don't start having like just bible
meetings in your house that's probably
better for you not to do that to
actually try to like connect with other
other people
because you have that like people do
that all the time like it's like they
don't like all the churches they find so
they're like i'm gonna start my own
church and then they become pastors so
and so self self declared pastor stone
so
and that's not great ah okay
okay
well
that was really fun we should do that
again that didn't even scratch the
surface of of questions but maybe send
me that book i'll read that book yeah
any time like i would i'd be very happy
to to talk to any time
cool okay i'm gonna take you up on that
offer it was nice meeting you all right
it's good to meet you
so
[Music]
you